in Americans election headquarters
tonight the ideological divisions within
the Democratic Party are on full display
tonight last night during a candidate
debate if you expected attacks on
someone who has already won the
presidency you were not disappointed but
you probably did not predict who that
would be correspondent Peter Doocy has
the surprising answer tonight from
Detroit
forget hope and change most candidates
are hoping for a change from the way
President Obama governed I was a little
surprised at how much income he was
about Barack that's right Democrats
spent the debate dissing the legacy of
Barack Obama and by extension his VP for
deporting too many illegal immigrants I
didn't hear whether you tried to stop
them or not I've learned the lessons of
the past and the vice president hasn't
you invoke President Obama more than
anybody in this campaign you can't do it
when it's convenient the Trump
administration Zimmy Gration policy was
attacked too for detaining migrant
children lawmakers have only seen from
afar climbed a stepladder they are
children Paris later hit Biden because
she thinks he'd leave millions uninsured
with a health policy modeled on
Obamacare for a Democrat to be running
for president with a plan that does not
cover everyone I think is without excuse
Biden shot back Medicare for all costs
trillions too much that's a lot of money
when criminal justice came up Cory
Booker coined a phrase that sums up his
frustration with a front-runner who once
supported a tough 1994 crime bill
dipping into kool aid and you don't even
know the flavor in the last debate
Kamala Harris stood out and since then
Tulsi Gabbard has been studying her
resume
she put over 1,500 people in jail for
marijuana violations and then laughed
about it when she was asked if she ever
smoked marijuana records show gabbard's
math is right but not all that went to
jail under attorney general Harris were
prosecuted by her now Harris is
shrugging off attacks by a congresswoman
who once visited Syrian dictator Bashar
al-assad I take those attacks with only
so much
now the question is did Joe Biden
protect his lead he's confident in his
performance but admits his closing could
have been better go to Joe 303 3
Oh that was not an announcement of a
campaign in 30 30 or an ATM PIN number
instead of saying Joe I would have said
text it's a curious calculation
candidates made to attack Barack Obama's
legacy last night because if somebody
other than Jill Biden wins the
nomination they might call Barack Obama
and ask for help campaigning and Barack
Obama might say is busy that day